Some things in life are surprising
But did you know that most alcohol beverages
contain all 13 minerals necessary to sustain your life?
or that approximately one percent of the world's population
is drunk at any given moment?
maybe you're one of them.
Or how about the fact that a single sperm has
has the equivalent of 37.5 megabytes of DNA information in it?
This  means that a normal ejaculation
acquaints to a data transfer of over 1500 terabytes.
Tell that to an iguana, koala or Komodo dragon
which all have two penises.
Or better yet, the kangaroo
which actually has three vaginas.
The male octopus, on the other hand
often tears of its mating arm
places it inside the female
and then swims off somewhere to die.
How romantic.
The average person walks the equivalent of three times
around the world in a lifetime.
Meanwhile, if the population of China walk pass you in a single foul line
it would take about 30 years
considering the rate of reproduction.
but after only 2 weeks,
a pair of their pants will have grown 1000 bacteria on the front
2500 on the back, and 10,000 on the crotch.
And did you know that the Apple iPhone is the
second best-selling product of all time,
after the Rubik's cube?
which actually has 43,252,003,274,489,856,000 possible configurations.
Much like a deck of cards, which, when shuffled
will result in a configuration that has never existed ever before.
How can this be?
The simple mathematical calculation shows that
the possible arrangements of a deck of cards
are monumental
Or how about the fact that
oxygen is required for combustion
and hydrogen is flammable gas, but together,
they make water, which puts fire out.
Before the eraser was invented,
bread was used to remove pencil marks,
while peanut butter, under extremely high pressure,
can be turned into diamonds?
That's...one useful sandwich.
And if you feel like a warm cup of coffee with that,
Try yelling for 8 years, 7 months and 6 days
which should produce enough sound energy
to heat your coffee up.
Strange as it may be, the brain actually named itself
and finally, a physicist studying atoms,
is really just atoms trying to understand themselves.
Got a burning question you want to answer?
Ask them in the comments, or on Facebook and Twitter.
and subscribe for more weekly science videos!